[Musik]
sie alle wollen auf und davon
die bündner sabrina und markus blum mit
tochter amira suchen das einfache leben
in der kanadischen wildnis vom zürcher
oberland nach kambodscha monika lehnert
und peter kruse erfüllen sich den traum
vom eigenen kleinen gasthaus carolin
schneider und daniel schafer aus dem
kanton bern ziehen mit ihren stücken
hunden nach schweden wo sie eine
campinganlage führen
[Musik]
in diesem flugzeug sitzen drei viertel
der familie blumen mutter sabrina
tochter amira und babynahrung sie landen
auf dem katiba sehen es ist mitten im
kanadischen sommer am ufer wartet nicht
etwa vater markus sondern der junge
teran der 15-jährige wald hier in den
ferien eine art bootcamp verbunden mit
kleineren arbeiten webinar ist nun vier
monate alt sie ist mit ihrer mutter
hierher geflogen weil schweizer gäste
zur takeda hütte kommen mag es wird bald
mit ihnen eintreffen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
sabrina ist zurück in der wildnis zurück
im leben zwischen gewehr und baby in der
letzten folge legten die blums mit der
frisch geborene lehrer noch in prinz
charles 60
die familie genoss die vorzüge des
städtischen lebens bevor sie wieder in
die abgeschiedenheit aufbrach in
kambodscha nutzten peter und monika die
regenzeit und die bäder umzubauen
für die hochsaison wollten sich die
auswanderer hilfe mit der
servicefachangestellte neveling
schwierige zeiten herrschen in schweden
carolin und daniel führen die
campinganlage bald nur noch zu zweit mit
auswanderer rollfeld sich entschlossen
wegzuziehen
seine hunde brachte er bereits zu ihrem
neuen zuhause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommen wir stellen den technisch zu weit
nach vorne so ein kleines geschöpfen er
war noch nie in der ckt damit ebenso
wenig wie eine babywippe hält erinnerst
du dich im hosensack sabrina scheint
aufgeregt zu sein
sie steht unter einer doppelbelastung
einerseits die erwartung der drei gäste
die bald eintreffen andererseits die
ansprüche ihre kinder
[Musik]
darin begrüßt trick der sein großonkel
ist liegt für den tross mit acht firmen
und fünf menschen an
seit zehn tagen reiten sie schon durch
die wildnis kanadas
heute war es ein besonders langer tag im
sattel
die schweizer familie giorgio ist
erschöpft markus blum kennt die familie
die talkshow von seiner früheren arbeit
als sportartikelverkäufer in davos
die letzten drei tage ihre abenteuer
ferien wird die gruppe nur noch in der
takata hütte verbringen
[Musik]
ja
nur zu zweit heute seit einem jahr lebt
peter kruse nun in kambodscha er scheint
mittlerweile gut integriert zu sein
was wollt ihr zum trinken die
servicefachangestellte evelin tanz aus
graubünden ist für drei monate in guest
house um mitzuhelfen ich sie willkommen
heißt wie setzen sie sich doch bitte die
beiden polizisten hat peter anlässlich
einer verkehrskontrolle kennengelernt
das nervt die haben sich da nicht ein
jetzt probleme wieder muss ich nicht
haben der tochter oder der helm
vergessen oder der winkel zum fenster
und hat den vorteil dass beter wie also
für das kleine geschenke erhalten die
freundschaft
monika trifft im gasthaus ein gerade
noch rechtzeitig denn es hat sich eine
grössere schweizer reisegruppe
angekündigt die besucher aus der
innerschweiz gehören zu einer gruppe der
schwinger und folklore freunde und sind
auf einer dreiwöchigen asienreise die 22
jährige evelyn arbeitet als volontärin
in guest house dafür erhält sie kost und
logis und 50 dollar sackgeld pro monat
evelyn soll monika entlasten die
probleme mit den beinen hat wir stehen
ist gift für sie merkten sie ist auf der
tour und neugierig schaut frau wand
durch den sound die frau des regionalen
polizeichefs ist die vermieterin vom
gästehaus und wohnt gleich nebenan
sie scheint der frau zu sein über das
rege treiben dem swiss gaben denn sie
führt etwas im schilde
leider hat sich zeit
[Musik]
am 1
auf der campinganlage sancho baden ist
der herbst eingekehrt es ist der tag des
abschieds
[Musik]
rolf kaiser packt sein hab und gut
er wird mit frau silvia und tochter lena
in sein neues zuhause ziehen
nur wenige kilometer vom sancho garten
entfernt
[Musik]
ein stockwerk tiefer im restaurant läuft
der betrieb wie gewohnt weiter carolin
schneider bewirtet gäste mit einem lunch
buffet
ursprünglich war der ausgebildete koch
rolf dafür vorgesehen das restaurant zu
führen
doch die zusammenarbeit funktionierte
nicht wie erhofft
[Musik]
ohneeinander lebewohl zu sagen
trennen sich die auswanderer
die trennung der auswanderer ist wie
eine beziehung die in die brüche geht
am ende sind es viele kleine probleme
die sich auftürmen und niemand weiß mehr
so recht wie es so weit kommen konnte
zurück bleibt wie so oft leere und
unverständnis und schoss aus der schweiz
definitiv fundierter fahrer was ihr
zögern oder im zug lässig oder der user
zirkler - da hat eigentlich noch nicht
genau wo htc und samsung
die einstigen freunde haben sich privat
und geschäftlich auseinandergelebt
[Musik]
der morgen bricht an anja kathi dass sie
sabrina bereitet das frühstück vor
sie ist für das leibliche wohl der gäste
zuständig neben ihre mutter dasein für
die kinder bleibt momentan weniger zeit
übrig die gäste haben vorrang
diese haben wie fast immer die letzten
zehn nächte im zelt geschlafen
[Musik]
einer hat bestimmt unbequemer geschlafen
als die gäste der junge herren hat es
ein nachtlager unter einem baum
wie hast du geschlafen
du siehst zerknitterte aus es ist ein
prächtiger tag markus bricht mit den
gästen auf zu einer fischer tour auf den
chart edersee sabrina geht derweil mit
den kindern in den wald um beeren
zusammen
die blues haben eine klare
aufgabenteilung markus ist der
reiseführer für die gäste und sabrina
kocht für sie dass die kinder mit dabei
sind wurde vorher mit der familie di
giorgio abgesprochen
sie zeigte sich einverstanden
plötzlich verschlechtert sich das wetter
für rick und deren es vorbei mit der
ruhe
sie wissen dass markus mit seinen gästen
ja immer noch auf dem see unterwegs ist
recht so
[Applaus]
ich glaube sie waren nicht weit von
diesen punkt dort entfernt vielleicht
sind sie in die bucht zur jagte die
gefahren
aber so sicher scheint sich rick nicht
zu sein und sabrina macht sich langsam
sorgen
eine stunde später ist das brot endlich
in sicht die erleichterung bei sabrina
ist riesig
[Gelächter]
während des unwetters von die gruppe
schutz in einer jagdhütte auf der
anderen seeseite so verlief alles
gründlich und wurde zu einem
eindrücklichen erlebnis
das gästehaus wiesbaden ist eingemietet
in der einen hälfte eines großen hauses
im anderen teil des anwesens und die
besitzerin frau wanda doch nicht mehr
lange denn sie baut ein neues haus und
wird ausziehen
nun überlegen sich monika und peter das
ganze haus zu mieten und so ihr
guesthouse auszubauen die hausherrin
frau wanda begrüßt die schweizer
auswanderer und übernimmt persönlich die
führung durch die villa die
hausangestellte party ist mit von der
partie um übersetzungshilfe zu leisten
den schlüssel baumkronen der bildungsrat
max floater
zwar stehen dort zur schule
pauli hat sich als größter c virus
handelt ein eigenes auto oder die große
sportevent werden und das wäre jetzt
zurück ich habe bis gehobenen alters
trust musste ich natürlich ganz
doch die hausbesitzerin nimmt nicht nur
eine möbel mit sondern sogar die dusche
sie teilt pari mit wie viele
monatsmieten sie als kaution im voraus
haben möchte sie will zehn monaten
das ist viel zu viel für uns wir schauen
uns einen spät und zeitpunkt eines hat
peter schon gelernt wenn es um
verhandlungen geht nur nichts
überstürzen
wir müssen viel investieren für eine
dusche für alle möbel alles sehr teuer
das ist das problem die vermieterin gibt
überraschend schnell nach
sie will nur noch sechs monate ich muss
das mit monika erst mal durchrechnen
es scheint so als wäre frau walter sehr
darauf erpicht mit monika und peter
handelseinig zu werden
monika und peter kehren zu ihrem sechs
zimmer guesthouse zurück seit einem jahr
betreiben sie den swiss baden und können
unter dem strich sogar einen kleinen
finanziellen überschuss verbuchen
[Musik]
falls sie sich mit der vermieterin auf
einen preis einigen würde sich die größe
ihres gasthauses gleich verdoppeln
[Musik]
rolf kaiser kommt bei seinem neuen
zuhause an
es trägt den namen little river ranch da
ist zwischen zwei pärchen liegt für
seinen neuen schlittenhunde hat rolf
bereits eine zwingeranlage erstellt es
ist wieder einmal ein neues leben für
rolf kaiser zumindest was das wohnen
angeht beginnt alles wieder von vorne
das weckt frische lebensgeister in rolf
frau silvia die wohnung bereits ein
wenig eingerichtet das kapitel sancho
garten ist für beide abgeschlossen
[Musik]
beruflich haben rolf von silvia beide
eine anstellung gefunden er als koch und
sie als verkäuferin die schönste
veränderung für die dreieinhalbjährige
tochter lena sie hat nun ihr eigenes
zimmer
[Musik]
auch carolin schneider und daniel schaaf
verstehen vor einem neuanfang
sie haben ein jahr in dieser baracke
gewohnt nun können sie in die frei
gewordene wohnung im haupthaus ziehen
es ist eine lange zeit seit karin und
daniel zum letzten mal die treppe hinauf
in den ersten stock gestiegen sind wo
rolf mit seiner familie wohnte
[Musik]
die sich schon gar nicht bewusst was ich
auch ihre ehemalige wohn baracke wollen
sie in ein guesthouse umbauen
das macht ja das ist wichtig vor der
situation dass das einfach irgendwie die
spanisch war die ganze zeit daheim vor
dem fernseher haut
[Musik]
ein letzter reitausflug für die
feriengäste der familie blumen angeln
steht auf dem programm diesmal am fluss
bei den gästen beißen die fische nicht
so wie gewünscht
markus dagegen profitiert von seiner
großen erfahrung die er sich im letzten
jahr hat aneignen können
rick bereitet alles vor in erwartung
eines üppigen mittagessen
doch dann verlässt auch magnus das
anglerglück
rick ist für die arbeit im hintergrund
zuständig marcus held die gäste bei
laune
er bemüht sich vergeblich um noch mehr
fische
[Musik]
bremen sicher
anschluss bleibt es bei dem einen fisch
gerade genug für einen snack
[Applaus]
es gibt frisch
gr wiz
doch der fall reicht nicht für das
abendessen welches sie gerne nach hause
gebracht hätten
markus möchte seinen gästen ein
unvergessliches erlebnis in der wildnis
bieten das gegenteil von massentourismus
hat seinen preis 8000 franken pro person
ohne den flug von der schweiz nach
kanada
das ist eine extreme form verbunden ist
eben doch wahrscheinlich wäre durch die
letzte flussquerung dieser expedition
ferien steht an
die fast vierjährige am ihrer reitet in
einer trage vorrichtung auf dem rücken
ihres vaters mit ein gewisses risiko
dass markus nur ein geht bei der dieb
fehlt es ja gut kennt
[Musik]
zurück im camp wartet eine überraschung
es gibt doch fisch zum abendessen dank
dem jungen herren herren ist also der
lieferant des heutigen abend essen
ich bin so stolz auf dich ich habe mir
viel beigebracht
bernhard gleich sechs fische aus dem
wasser gezogen keine schlechte beute für
einen 15-jährigen der mitten in der
ausbildung zum kanadischen man steckt
[Musik]
die hauptsaison in dialog will ist noch
nicht angebrochen genügend zeit für die
schönen seiten des lebens
[Musik]
peter nutzt die gelegenheit das monika
mit evelyn beschäftigt ist ich habe eine
frage kannst du später zum markt fahren
eine goldkette als geschenk für monika
kaufen was kostet so eine 50 dollar
so eine änderung hätte wie du sie trägt
wenn ich sie kaufen geht dann sage ich
den doppelten ausländer preis ok kannst
du später gehen danke
die hausangestellte century fährt zum
markt in das zentrum von dialog will
monika und evelyn sind dabei schon fast
unten am mir das sind und wo sie
zusammen und geben sich ernährung ab und
zu erbringen mehreren park was aber und
die hände riese freut wenn sie auch ist
es brote bekommt wo halt zwei tagen
machen sie messen und so dem er sie bis
zu unterstützen
wir bringen auch stellen also ted und
dose bringen meiner zu ihnen
und ja mehrere machen also orientiertem
virtuell für den wenn wir schon am geld
ausgehen
[Musik]
seit juli ist beim markt angekommen hier
gibt es fast alles zu kaufen
kleider nahrungsmittel haushaltsartikel
und schmuck
[Musik]
bald wird sie fündig
peter möchte mit der kette seine monika
überraschend beim großen abendessen zum
ein jahres jubiläum ihrer auswanderung
zurück am strand
so lohnt sich das leben darum sei jetzt
schon einmal stark besetzt ist wird kann
also bitte kein glück mit den anderen
teilen
ich finde das ist eine tolle geschichte
wenn das duo wird freiwillig oder
privatpersonen
der ausflug machen zwei dagegen verstößt
ob das bei gott und die kamera locken
also ich begrüße jetzt die grünen mit
ihren dass ich auch mal mit ihrem tipp
ist ja reden so wie mir der schnabel
gewachsen ist ein buch studieren was
heißt das schon wieder auf irgendwelche
sprache und das fällt mir schon
routiniert denke dass mir das so verhält
drei monate wird evelyn hier in dialog
will bleiben
danach will sie mit dem rucksack weiter
durch südostasien reisen im sandschak
baden ist eine neue zeitrechnung
angebrochen
daniel schaffer ist mit seinen 16
schlittenhunden alleine in der großen
zwingeranlage
[Musik]
die führung des restaurants ist nun die
hauptaufgabe für carolin schneider
wobei daniel selbstverständlich mithilft
eigentlich sind die beiden schon seit
monaten auch als sie noch zu viert auf
dem sand garden waren für die
gastronomie zuständig die feuerprobe
haben sie bereits hinter sich
die hauptsaison durch den sommer die
führung des restaurants beansprucht viel
zeit und die restliche arbeit auf der
campinganlage erledigt sich auch nicht
von selbst situation ist mit hildegard
barth oder hut bringen das ist
restauration das ist das ist es ist
ungeheuer innovationen ein neugieriger
beteiligen
therese große dem und gästebetreuung mit
einer punktuellen seehofer das ist mit
zu tragen mit hoch wie es organisiert
oder so was knallhart presse ist es
machbar
paulin und daniel haben nun eine ganze
saison auf der campinganlage hinter sich
mit warmen und kalten zeiten mit vielen
und wenigen gästen
sie können nun abschätzen was auf sie
wartet die strengste zeit liegt hinter
ihnen
[Musik]
gold kommt der ruhige winter und mit ihm
die aussicht auf traumhafte
schlittenfahrten mit ihren hunden
[Musik]
abreisetag in kanada ein zwischenfall
verzögerte den abflug
markus muster in 16 grad kalte wasser
springen das boot hatte sich gelöst und
drohte abzutreiben die gäste werden nun
zurück in die zivilisation gefunden
die zwei wochen in der wildnis hat die
gruppe zusammengeschweißt
[Musik]
es ist der erste von insgesamt vier
flügen die es braucht bis die familie
die georgia wieder sicher in der schweiz
landet die blues müssen noch die pferde
in das hauptlager zurückbringen für den
moment scheinen sie gleichwohl
erleichtert achtung
[Musik]
und er hat sich wirklich die krönung
versagt
also eine träumerei oder auch für
familie blumen ist ein traum in
erfüllung gegangen mit der fähre tour
konnten sie ihre faszination für das
wilde kanada weiter geben und
gleichzeitig geld verdienen
doch das reicht nicht um ihr leben zu
finanzieren die blues haben einen plan
wie sie ihr dasein hinter fremde sichern
können
und dieser plan wird sie vorübergehend
in die schweiz zurück führen
[Musik]
gelöste stimmung in kambodscha peter ist
in spendierlaune ein letzter akt der
großzügigkeit bevor er für heute den
laden dicht macht ich habe hunger
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt jetzt da die
servicefachangestellte evelyn im
gasthaus mithilft können peter und
monika zum aller ersten mal gemeinsam
mit ihren angestellten in einem
restaurant essen gehen
es gibt ein jubiläum zu feiern seit
einem jahr leben die auswanderer nun in
kambodscha bei der jahrestag feiern mit
dabei sind die beiden hausangestellten
sreto und pari der nachtwächter und der
tuk tuk fahrer
peta setzt an eine kleine rede zu halten
ich möchte sagen es ist nun ein jahr her
seit monika und ich den swiss baden
übernommen habe und ich denke es ist der
beste ort den wir finden konnten und ihr
seid das beste team das wir haben können
ich hoffe dass wir die nächsten 10 15
jahre bei monika und teuer bleibt für
das erste jahr in kambodscha übergebe
ich monika ein kleines geschenk
[Musik]
wie hat es gekauft
es ist ein jahr her seit monika lehnert
und peter kruse nach kambodscha
auswanderten
sie wagten viel sie verließen ein
sicheres angestelltenverhältnis und
begaben sich in die selbstständigkeit
spontan beschlossen sie ein guesthouse
in kambodscha zu übernehmen entgegen
aller widerstände folgten sie unbeirrbar
ihrem bauchgefühl welche sie letztlich
nicht im stich lassen sollte
mit viel herz erfüllten sie sich den
traum vom eigenen kleinen gäste aus dass
vielleicht bald größer wird die
verhandlungen mit der vermieterin sind
auf gutem weg
[Musik]
davos anfang dieses jahres markus blum
ist auch besuch in jener stadt die er
vor anderthalb jahren verlassen hat
heute abend feiert er premiere mit dem
diavortrag über die abenteuer von ihm
und seiner familie 30 vorführungen sind
geplant durch die ganze schweiz mit
nicht
es ist ein heimspiel für die blums nach
monaten in der abgeschiedenheit sind
sabrina und markus nun mitten im rummel
verschafft
noch bevor
[Musik]
august nun herzlich gesammelt dort ihre
heimat zum ersten mal erzählt markus
seinen familienabenteuer vor einem
großen publikum sollte raten ob braucht
darüber bringt ohne dir gott nämlich gar
nicht punkt eins das ist reiselust
abenteuerlust dass das angebot ist sie
aber verhindern dass er genau das ist
viel schwieriger und somit jährigen
punkt 2 bei der frau ein fahrrad finde
das ist im leben sowieso die absolute
stoße dort weil ich sie für das eine
orgel und brauchte
punkte sind das ist wiederum sehr auf
den punkt zwei abschnitte
es ist eine außergewöhnliche geschichte
die markus blumen zu erzählen hat die
geschichte einer familie die das
einfache leben suchte im wissen dass sie
als familie das kostbarste gut immer mit
sich trägt das vertrauen dass man
zusammengehört so werden die blums nach
der die atome wieder in ihre neue heimat
kanada zurückkehren und ihren familien
album ein weiteres kapitel hinzufügen
[Musik]
in schweden ist tiefster winter die frag
mich aber wieder sehr schwer mit dem
auge zurück und die zeremonie zwar noch
lieber mit der stadt im laden immer
wieder rückt dann gibt es schon nicht
gerade noch vergeben hätte angst und
spielt karoline und daniel haben eine
intensive zeit hinter sich
eine zeit die leer sie gemeinsam durchs
feuer gehen und sich wieder neu
kennenlernen so oft tristen und es macht
super show interessiert für die und es
ist zwar aus kurz ist perfekt
es ist aus da war nix sie aber irgendwie
hat man sich einfach löschen
märz mit sie zwar arbeitet dass das maus
team gut funktionieren hat der soll der
15 jährige sergej lawrow gemeinschaft
dem bett kommt dann und nur dann über
und bis zu grauen nach einer frage was
sein kann
also wird das die bezeichnung auch hat
sich also für mich das wirklich der weg
von meinem traum dass wir hand in hand
ein anderer für das ist schon absolut
und so verbirgt sich hinter der
auswilderung von caroline und daniel
eine große liebesgeschichte hand in hand
heraustreten aus dem alltag in der
schweiz aus dem beruflichen trott aus
der gewohnten zweisamkeit
gemeinsam in ein neues leben das immer
wieder anstrengend und mühsam sein mag
aber bestimmt nicht langweilig und
blutleer
wer auswandert folgt seiner sendung der
sehnsucht nach freiheit und veränderung
wie weiter das glück tatsächlich findet
weiß keiner der sich zur auswanderung
entschließt
es ist ein aufbruch ins große abenteuer
liga gefüge mit davon träumen
[Musik]
das neue ist offen